hi there and welcome to the fifth video
in our series on sre and devops my name
is Seth and I'm a developer advocate at
Google focused on infrastructure and
operations and I'm Liz and essary
focused on teaching Google cloud
customers how to build and operate
reliable services ok Liz so I've defined
my SLI and what are you wearing what do
you mean
the dress and miss flying forum it's
what we were in the future you're from
the future yes
just keep going it'll all make sense in
the end ok Liz as I was saying I've
defined my slis and my SLS and I
calculated my error budgets and my teams
are working together instead of fighting
and I'm done I've successfully
implemented DevOps and sre practices but
you have customers right I mean we tell
our investors that so if you have
customers they might want to connect
their servers to your service you have
an API right maybe well now you have to
teach your customers how to do DevOps
and essary wait so you're saying that
all of the stuff we've talked about in
all of these videos I have to go teach
that to my customers yes yes you do but
all of those things like toil and error
budgets and slis and SLO is all of that
well you technically don't have to but
have you ever had a user be angry at you
because your service is down yeah well
what happens if your service behaves in
a way that's inspect for your
beautifully crafted SL O's but that
breaks a customer expectation yeah I can
see that and I you know no one likes
unhappy users and we certainly don't and
you can imagine that at google scales
that with that many unhappy users we'd
want to do something about it so anytime
you have a consumable service that has
an API that's going to happen and the
best way to make for your customers to
be happy is to communicate clearly about
how your services intended to behave
which coincidentally means exposing your
SOS to them interesting so I have to
teach them how to make a good SLO for
their systems and that will teach them
how to interact correctly with my system
exactly okay but I'm not sure I follow
like how is it gonna help it seems like
a lot of upfront work so once upon a
time we didn't talk about SOA publicly
and we thought of it as our secret sauce
and we tried to keep it secret and then
we learned a very hard lesson our
customers had problems and they had
problems because they'd use their
systems in ways that we weren't
expecting and that neither of us were
communicating about we didn't tell our
customers how our systems were designed
and they didn't tell us what they were
expecting and then when everything broke
they got very upset and you can imagine
that multiplied by millions or billions
of users well I mean at Google scale I
can imagine how that would quickly add
up over time yep it sure did and we
learned eventually that we can move
faster and shift features to our
customers faster if we're openly
communicating with our customers and
helping them do sre so the time that we
spend teaching people about how to do
sre why is it paying off a lot because
when users apply these things to their
systems
it makes them have much less friction
with us I see so an initial upfront
investment on education or on sre has
long-term dividends exactly and it was
so successful that now we have an entire
team which is the team that I'm part of
the customer reliability engineering
team or CRE and series are regular
Google s eries that are focused
externally instead of working on our own
GCP applications we instead help
customers who are implementing their
applications on GCP and we help them
also employ a necessary practices like
SL isin s ellos and that means that in
the long term we can share information
we can share our SL o--'s with our
customers and have our customers share
their s lows with us so that we'll know
if we break one of our customers or our
customers can figure out whether an
issue they're seeing is a glitch on
their end or whether it's something
that's in GCP that's so cool Thanks
future Liz
[Music]
that was weird
I'm sorry I'm late Seth everything okay
and I hope I didn't throw off the
schedule
not a problem we're just talking to a
future version of yourself wait a future
version of me that's so cool so you're
saying future me invented a time machine
and then went back in time so as to make
me not late to this exactly that's
really cool what did she say so we were
talking about the customer reliability
engineering program or the CRT program
here at Google but I'm still a little
bit unclear about how it plays into this
bigger DevOps picture uh yes so Siri is
customer reliability engineering and we
focus on breaking down the
organizational barriers not between
individual silos and a single company
but instead between a cloud customer and
its platform provider and we also think
about how do we make failure a normal
accepted thing so for instance we make
sure that everyone has serviceable
objectives and error budgets so we
communicate about what's an acceptable
level of reliability so that everyone
doesn't panic when there's a little bit
of downtime and also we focus a lot on
measurement so we make sure that
everyone has visibility into the system
so that customers can see how the
platform is performing and the platform
can see how the customer service will
objectives are faring during an outage
so in that way we have a single pane of
glass between everyone great thanks Liz
and thank you everyone for watching
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and stay tuned for future videos and
maybe a future Liz check out the
description below for more information
about customer reliability engineering
at Google